[Music]
nobody wants their favorite show to end
especially if it ends on a weird note
but yet there are many shows out there
that really made us go huh when we watch
the season finale stay tuned for the
show that should really get the ultimate
dark twist award don't forget to give
this video a thumbs up and subscribe to
the things now let's check out 10
surprisingly dark series finales in
kid-friendly shows Teen Titans we often
talk about Teen Titans go on this
channel but the original Teen Titans
deserve a mention too if you've seen the
series finale you know it took a
surprisingly dark turn no one really
expected Teen Titans is also where were
first introduced to Tara who puts a
totally new spin on the topics of
betrayal and starting a romance just for
her own personal benefit Teen Titans was
never really the type of show that would
shy away from keeping it real but
perhaps it got a bit too real in the
last season in the last episode we
learned that Tara comes back after
betraying Beast Boy after questioning it
for a while it's confirmed that it is in
fact Tara even though she for some
reason claims to not remember Beast Boy
at all this obviously completely breaks
beast boy's heart
Slade tells Beast Boy that Tara doesn't
want to remember him which is definitely
not good news for those of us that loved
this strange relationship then beast boy
discovers Slade is a robot possibly sent
by Tara herself what is actually going
on we're then told the biggest life
lesson that things change and
relationships can take an unexpected
turn just like that
harsh full house the original full house
was a show most of the 90s kids grew up
with it taught us some of the biggest
life lessons about family love as well
as growing up but for some reason things
took a strange turn
during the final episode here's a little
memory refresher if you need one in the
final episode we learned that Michelle
lost her memory from falling off a horse
her amnesia is pretty strong and she
doesn't remember any of her family to
the point where she asks whether they
all live in that small house the story
goes on and things get a little bit sad
when her dad has to explain again why
Michelle doesn't have a
her mom passed away six months after
giving birth to Michelle as a result of
a car crash as the Olsen twins character
was the glue that held full house
together seeing her completely lose her
memory and question everything was
totally unexpected for a kids show of
course it all ends on a happy note and
we even get to see both Olsen twins on
screen overall the full house finale
opened up some unexpected wounds the
characters have been trying to heal for
a really long time we can't even imagine
what Danny was feeling when Michelle
asked him about her mom Digimon Tamers
as a series that was clearly inspired by
Pokemon you'd expect a demon to have the
same type of happy feeling as you watch
it well it kind of did until the third
season things took a really dramatic and
dark turn as Jerry tried to fight off
her depression after her mother passed
away
it makes things even worse when you
realize that Jerry was only ten years
old
Digimon didn't end on a happy note at
all it made things even darker for Jerry
and her Digimon who ended up passing
away to Jerry's anger only grew to the
point where she became possessed by the
D Reaper who completely controlled her
emotions and told her that humans don't
deserve to live then she even got
trapped and had horrible flashbacks and
relived the passing of her loved ones
all over again her depression reached a
boiling point when she tried to choke
herself in an attempt to end her life as
she was completely controlled by the D
Reaper it's definitely not the story
you'd expect from a season finale at all
and we're pretty sure it messed up a lot
of kids that loved watching the show of
course after that rollercoaster it all
does eventually ends on a happy note
with Jerry overcoming her depression but
it definitely introduces kids to a dark
world a regular show regular show
definitely deserved an hour-long season
finale but none of us were really
prepared for it when it happened it
starts with an epic battle that will
decide the fate of the universe and if
that's not scary enough we're not sure
what is it's pops versus anti pops and
their fight completely destroys the
entire universe to be fair what else did
we expect from a show like this it also
regenerates it but no one even expected
that the fight between the two brothers
would have such
impact on the entire regular show
universe and what's up with Benson and
the whole robot thing of course the show
still managed to squeeze in some
morbidly funny moments like when the
human shield number two became human
shield number one but overall no one
really suspected the season finale to
take such a dark turn we still managed
to see what the characters look like
after the universes rebirth however the
whole thing might be just a little bit
too much for young viewers the finale
was the creator's favorite episode and
while it might make sense on the larger
scale it was still a totally bizarre way
to end this awesome show ow
here's a little throwback for 90s kids
that probably grew up with this bizarre
show in case you've never heard of it
Alf is the only survivor of a planet
called melmac and he comes in to live
with the Tanner family and in case
you're wondering his actual name is
Gordon but the family called him Alf
which meant alien life form the family
protects Alf
from the alien task force that is ready
to do really bad things to him in the
final episode alpha learns that he's not
the sole survivor of his old planet he
gets torn between wanting to stay with
the family or join the planet
colonization it turns out it was all
just a coincidental fate to actually
catch out who is then caught by the
alien task force the series officially
ends with the agents capturing Alf and
presumably torturing him seriously and
this was a kid-friendly show no one saw
that coming of course they later also
produced a movie to explain that Alf was
still alive but in a brand new twist he
doesn't even seem to remember the Tanner
family sorry that's pretty much all the
dark news we can take this whole thing
sounds horrific Roseanne back in the 90s
kids were totally allowed to watch shows
that were meant for the entire family
series like Roseanne had plenty of
inappropriate moments but because kids
had limited access to typical
Nickelodeon shows we had to take what we
got but no one expected the already
weird show known as Roseanne to end in a
way it did seriously it probably was one
of the weirdest moments in television
ever the entire season is pretty weird
but finale takes the cake when Roseanne
reveals that she's actually been writing
a book and the show is her own work of
fiction
how meta is this she continues that
everything is a frost narrative
to fit in better with her own book so in
reality the Connors never won the
lottery dan passed away from a heart
attack
Jackie was gay and so on we were pretty
much lied to about the storyline of our
favorite characters and the way it's
been played out it's kind of messed up
it's even weirder because the entire
show just ends with Roseann looking at
her book then going upstairs and sitting
on the couch that's it that's how it
ends it's dark it's twisted and we're
still not over it
Samurai Jack we all want our favorite
characters to have a happy ending but
that's not always the case in fact
Samurai Jack probably had one of the
most heartbreaking endings ever and the
fandom still has a lot of questions that
were left unanswered we were all rooting
for the Jack and Ashley's storyline but
then it got brutally taken away in a
twist no one really expected and we're
still not over it
Jack does end up defeating aku but it
does so in the past when ashes powers
managed to transport them back to where
it all started they finally managed to
defeat aku and everything is set up for
a happy ending Jack and Ashley are
finally set to get married when things
really take a dramatic turn they both
realize that without a clue existing
they would have never met and as she
would never be there to begin with
upon that realization as she begins to
disappear it's a traumatic moment seeing
jack holding Ashley in his arms as she
disappears away it's a dark reminder
that even though Jack saved the lives of
many he couldn't save the person he
loved the most it's incredibly
heartbreaking and dark but an
interesting twist in a lesson that you
should never alter the past because
everything happens for a reason
Batman the Animated Series everyone has
an opinion on the Batman the Animated
Series and while the show was already
dark to begin with it seems at the
ending rile to find a few feathers the
show's finale focuses on Harley Quinn
and presents a pretty dark side of being
trapped in an abusive relationship as
the Joker quickly makes fun of Harley
for trying to end Batman's life he hits
Harley so hard she flies out the window
their relationship also highlights so
many abusive relationships where the
victims blame themselves and convince
themselves that it's entirely their
fault this is also the case of Harley
right before she passes out as
episode goes on Harley tries really hard
to separate herself from the Joker
because she knows deep down that he's
bad but in the end she comes back down
of course there are also plenty of other
creepy moments through the finale but
the relationship between Harley and the
Joker is constantly highlighted as
abusive and yet there are plenty of fans
that are still romanticizing it because
let's be honest they also had a couple
of good moments through the series
overall this ending was extremely
eye-opening and terrifying Foster's Home
for Imaginary Friends this beloved
Cartoon Network show definitely deserves
more credit but all fans just want to
erase the season finale although it's
not as dark as some of the other shows
we've mentioned the finale leaves with a
cliffhanger no one really expected or
wanted the episode starts with Eduardo
crying which is already heartbreaking
everyone's getting ready for Mac's
surprise farewell party as his mom
announces that he's leaving but at the
end Mac explains something pretty sad
he's moving apartments where they don't
allow imaginary friends but what's more
messed up than this is the theory behind
Foster's home disappearing in the final
credits it's assumed that since these
imaginary friends only lived in Mac's
imagination Mac officially said goodbye
to them hence the home actually
disappeared since the apartment where
Mac's moving to doesn't allow imaginary
friends doesn't mean that Mac finally
outgrew them let's not debate this
theory anymore because we all want
Foster's Home for Imaginary Friends to
be a real place now go hug your
imaginary friend and tell them you'll
never leave them like math left blue
gravity falls okay perhaps the biggest
surprise ever was when gravity falls
announced that season two will be the
last season of the show the entire
season was ultimately much darker than
the first one which is already
surprising for a kids show anyways the
three-part season finale was completely
epic but also pretty dark considering it
was the beginning of the apocalypse and
a weird one at that then there's Mabel's
fake reality in which they're all traps
and the gang attempting to stop bill
after they learn about his true motives
bill even takes a really dark turn when
he wants to end Mabel and dipper which
is dark even for a show like gravity
falls it's a very pleasing ending but
it's just so surprising that this was
ever a
friendly show because it's so dark bill
screaming that he might return was also
pretty creepy because let's be honest
nobody wants to see him back anyways
overall it's our favorite season finale
out of all we've shown you today but
there's still so much creepy value to it
we honestly think it's not even
kid-friendly what do you think let us
know your thoughts in the comments below
and that's all for our video don't
forget to subscribe to the things and
tell us how you felt about this video
thanks for watching see you next time
[Music]